the Joe Rogan experience Joshy actually
got the DNA test okay can we talk about
how [ __ ] up Ticketmaster is real quick
yeah you wanted to talk about I just
figured that I just put my mind together
on this thing yeah there's a taxi sent
me oh my god
ticket my fat model at Ticketmaster
we're gonna take them all down okay so
take a master you know the place where
you buy tickets I had no clue about this
take a master thing I'm just starting to
do some theaters and [ __ ] on the tour so
I'm starting to look at like what they
charge to do like the processing and
servicing right you baile it's like a
thirty or forty dollar ticket I looked
at yours forty our tickets sixteen
dollars in servicing for a service
charge yeah is it per ticket per [ __ ]
ticket forty percent on they gotta pay
for [ __ ] in a venue like no they don't
that's the venue cost that you also
gotta pay yeah it's just to process the
ticket and if you want to pick up the
we'll call another three dollars it's
unfathomable right so I'm starting to
think I'm going okay so for the first
time in my life I'm like okay I'm I'm
selling some tickets everything's good
and I'm just getting peace of the door
so I'm happy right and my boy who's like
this genius [ __ ] kid Oh Jay Nigerian
all these Nigerians are geniuses and he
comes up to me he's like okay but what
about the processing fee for tikka
matter how much are you getting off of
that I go what it was like what
percentage you getting off that I got
nothing he was wait but you're bringing
all the ticket sales why aren't you
getting a piece of it's 40% of your
ticket price and I'm like well I don't
know and he goes and what about the data
from the tickets being sold are you
getting that I don't know he goes hold
on so they're [ __ ] you and getting
paid to [ __ ] you I go what do you mean
he goes the game is data now any
business is successful right now is all
about data acquisition right any
business and data is not how many
followers we have on Instagram because
they could take your account away in a
second how many subs do you get on
YouTube because they could throttle your
search we could see that happen all the
time it's direct connect to fan right
and what Ticketmaster has done is
they're your ticketing site they get
your email they get your data set they
get all your fans they know exactly who
your fans are and they email them and
tell them when you're coming into town
or when somebody else that they might
like that's like you exactly and then
they're getting paid an absorbing amount
of money they're [ __ ] over the fans
on it so I'm like I'm talking to him and
he's like yo we got to just create
another one of these we've got to create
another system that gives all that data
to the comic why is the middleman even
there we could create a way cheaper
ticketing service that gives every one
of those emails to a comic and it's like
comics used to do back in the days by
putting the comment cards on the tables
and you collect them afterwards you
could have an email list for every time
you go to Idaho an email list for every
time you go to New Jersey and email list
for all these different prices but most
authors do and Kevin Hart Kevin Hart
that's how Kevin Hart came up Kevin Hart
was going into all of these comedy clubs
and he was getting everybody's
[ __ ] email people wonder why
whenever Kevin would launch on these
social media sites he'd get all of these
crazy followers immediately it's because
of that road work he put in in those
comedy clubs anybody before anybody I
think louis c.k did that as well we had
this massive email and now you have
direct connection with your fans yeah
and that's what your fans want your fans
don't want Ticketmaster telling them
that Led Zeppelin's coming through they
want to know when Brogan's comes through
but you know Pearl Jam tried to fight
them back in the day what they have they
have exclusive deals with certain venues
they are top to bottom yeah they own so
they own Live Nation and Live Nation
owns a venue so they're complete
vertical e integrated so if you want to
plant the garden or whatever the [ __ ] it
is right yeah so you go we're gonna
process your tickets the only way you do
is perform here is you do with our
promotion company which is live the
nation and you're gonna have to use our
ticket processing fee and and our venue
they actually own the venue's now but
here's the thing there's a handful of
you guys that get to play those venues
now I think with podcasts now shows our
300 people there's gonna be thousands of
comics that have 300 fans and the venue
where we perform is not imperative that
it's this specific one it could be a
comedy club it could be a hall it could
be some conference center it could be
anything it could be Airbnb but aren't
you only going to your math thing when
you're doing these bigger venues well
sometimes now that they're Live Nation
they own some certain clubs well I do I
work with Live Nation so now all your
[ __ ] is that same stand-up
yeah really yeah why not just do the
podcast live every [ __ ] way different
man
it's insane yeah I like podcast like
this where it's just people talking well
you do it differently when you're
playing for an audience it's performed
for them and it becomes just weird
audience an issue it just is not a it's
not the same it's not a real
conversation like I think the intimacy
of podcasts one of the things that
people like about as they listen in
their ear right there
earplug it's like you're talking to them
yeah like you're right there when you're
doing it live it becomes a different
thing cuz remember that's a bad thing
yeah but it's a different thing to stand
up is way better way it's just way more
fun I'm saying is what are we doing with
this right it's like like you shouldn't
you should have a direct connect all
your fans
I should have Direct Connect all my fans
right we should be able to even the
venue should have that as well why why
do we why are we giving away all the
data yeah to a company that's really not
I know my agents gonna call me right
after this thing's gonna be like why the
[ __ ] we have to [ __ ] up so you want
their email you want your audience's
email of it and that's what the audience
wants and I don't want my audience to
get charged 16 bucks every time they buy
a ticket where does that money go like
it costs $16 a ticket forty percent of
the ticket price why not just create an
email and when you're at these venues
just put it up on the jumbotron and be
like yo email me after the email reality
show I mean that's yeah that's one more
step or we could just create the ticket
process in the charges on Way letter
less excuse me and and already starts
aggregating the emails and then if you
want to get real crazy with it you have
a boy of yours that like let's say my
buddy Akash right I do a podcast with
it's like hey Akash you're about to go
on tour yeah why don't you just use my
data set man they're gonna know you from
doing the podcast with me maybe you
could they'll want to see you it's like
we get to empower each other through
that [ __ ] am I making sense or no it
makes sense the thing is specific
specifically about data about the the
email list and about they get that if
you show up in these different places
they get the email address because
that's how people get their tickets what
you get that you get the option of
saying because they'll ask you they'll
say can Ticketmaster reply to you or can
take your math to send you the latest
updates and news and got it you can
click no yeah sure that's Ticketmaster
but you would click yes if it was us and
it was somebody who you were invested in
going to see you just don't want taking
mass for promoting random
offense/defense would you send me your
email address and might sell it
absolutely yeah even if you just click
no like you do want updates from
Ticketmaster you're not saying is it
okay if this company just starts selling
my email address because that's what
they do that's what they do yeah
rodeo owners anyway but they don't have
to I'm saying now like everybody that's
coming out to your shows is coming out
from this podcast they're not coming up
cuz I take a master and if you
use a different email service or
ticketing service they would come out
with that one
[Applause]